we love following you on Instagram I  mean you're beautiful pictures of you  especially breastfeeding so has that  helped lose the weight at all no that's  that's a myth I don't know who started  that myth but breastfeeding to me makes  it harder really fun yeah I don't know i  mean i think that there's got to be for  some women it just they'd hold on to the  fat to make the milk maybe I always say  when I'm breastfeeding I have like just  this light layer of fat over my body  like a like a seal or a walrus baby like  an elephant um I guess to make the milk  I don't know it is just an amazing  process that my body is giving her  nourishment women we are the most  perfect machine ever made